so here we have another ten of my view
video clips again themed on ethics I've
got quite a few of these that I'm going
to put together these all have to do
with specific issues and ethics like
stealing lying abortion business ethics
stripping athletes of titles all those
sorts of things that we would think of
as getting down to the nitty-gritty of
ethics and I had a lot of people ask me
questions about these sorts of things
both students and other V users so here
are ten of those clips
is it okay to lie sometimes if it's
beneficial or is lying always morally
wrong lying is always morally wrong well
actually that's a lie okay it's from my
perspective I am NOT a a strict de
ontological Duty based ethicist and I
think that there are some circumstances
in which it could be it could be okay to
lie and it might actually be the right
thing to do now I'm saying that of
course I'm I'm at odds with somebody
like a manual Conte I'm also at odds
with with somebody like st. Augustine
who discusses lying in a number of
different works and he ends up saying
something kind of interesting he says
lying is always morally wrong it's
always bad but there's a question of how
bad it is exactly because he has to deal
with certain issues that come up like
you know when when you lie to some that
somebody doesn't get hurt you know
insofar as it's a lie it's not good but
there are other considerations that
worked and if you think about the
broader context something which is at
least in some sense a lie way to
actually turn out to have good sides to
it so I don't want to say that lying is
ever in itself morally right or good but
I do want to say that it's not
necessarily morally wrong across the
board in every single
is it okay to lie if it's beneficial if
that's the whole of the idea that well
it's going to work out nice nicely for
me if I lie well that's not going to be
a good stance to take but there's a
broader considerations there good
question
so this is a question asked by one of my
current ethics students in my online
class that I'm teaching this summer and
it's a good question it's one that's
been asked throughout the ages stealing
is wrong or bad but if you were stealing
in order to feed your family as a truly
bad so really good question and I'm
going to take sort of two different
paths answering this one is let's say
that we're actually talking about
defining it as stealing we're going to
stick with that and we agree that
stealing is wrong or bad some moral
theories would say it's always bad no
matter what you know if you have a sort
of rule-based Duty based ethical system
then once you've got a rule in place
you've got a rule in place and you can
give some sort of justification for why
it would always be wrong if you have a
sort of consequentialist a particularly
to latarian moral theory in place where
you're saying well it really depends on
the consequences and this would have
good consequences and say maybe say they
wouldn't miss what's being stolen then
and it might actually be a good act not
necessarily the best act but maybe the
best in the circumstances another thing
that often comes up and you see this
actually comes Aquinas talking about
this we have to think about how we're
defining moral antics are we giving it
the best definition by calling it
stealing or would the emphasis truly be
on you know let's say there's there's a
man he's got a family to feed there's
absolutely no way to feed them unless
he's unless he takes this bread without
asking for it
has been denied him Thomas Aquinas
suggests and I think a lot of other
moral theorists would say this that
perhaps in that circumstance that act is
best described as something other than
stealing so those are all things to
think about
so how do I feel about the issue of
abortion big question and I think it's a
fair one to ask of anyone who put
themselves out there is a sort of public
philosopher or theologian I'm not a
theologian by the way or any sort of you
know figure like that I think that
abortion is a terrible thing I in fact
do believe that a fetus is a human being
I don't think it makes any sense to to
do what you know for instance the Casey
decision did and talk about you know
somebody's a human being if the other
person decides to treat them as a human
being I think that's a really dangerous
thing to do and I'm you know fully aware
of all the different complexities of the
issue and why somebody might feel
pressured to to do that given economic
circumstances or their current
relationship or their readiness to have
a child but I do think that in most
cases adoption is carrying the child
determined having an adoption is is the
answer now of course this leaves aside
all these questions what if the child is
damaged all these sorts of things and
you can raise those sort of things
interminably I will say this about about
my own case that myself I was actually
the product of a rape a date rape and it
would have been very easy in the
cultural climate that my my birth mother
lived to just go out and get an abortion
instead what she chose to do was to put
me up for adoption
after she found herself a hospital where
she could stay earn her keep
by working all the way up until the time
of labor to pay for the delivery and
make sure that I was going to go to a
family where I would be loved and cared
for well and that strikes me as a you
know heroic virtue not saying that can
be done in every case but I think it is
relevant that it can be done so complex
issue not a very good answer but
now this is a follow-up to some
questions that were asked a long while
ago to me about abortion as a moral
issue how do you know that abortion is
taking a human life it's not proven
either way well it kind of depends on
what you mean by by proven let's sort of
back up a little bit if you accept that
a fetus is a human life then you know
sort of by definition abortion it's
going to be taking a human life I heard
an interesting argument recently at an
ethics conference made by a a
philosopher who is talking about trying
to distinguish between being human and
being a person and he was he was trying
to claim that the embryo is already
human because as human genetic material
but it can't be said in any meaningful
way to be a person I think he wanted to
claim about the sixth month or so and
that the embryo itself you know
oftentimes the life begins at conception
is the assumption he was trying to say
it begins at implantation interesting
ideas now back to that it's not proven
either way it really depends an awful
lot on what you mean by proof if by that
you mean demonstrating something you
know with irrefutable logical
consistency you know once you actually
do enter down the road of this counts as
a human being this is killing a human
being you know you're going to end up at
this is taking a human life so if you
mean logical proof that's not a problem
maybe what you mean is figuring out when
we should actually talk about the the
embryo as being human myself I say you
know from the start but that's me
you
so what do I think about athletes being
stripped of titles metals things like
that due to steroids is there a
philosophical argument for or against
yeah yeah actually a philosophical
arguments all over thanks because
there's a lot of people out there doing
philosophy and there's even a lot of
people doing philosophy of sport I'm not
going to try to summarize all that
because you know not big on that that
literature and I have all the things
that I do if you want to know what I
think about it I'm all for it
I think if you won some sort of title or
a game or a competition and you weren't
supposed to be taking steroids and you
know that led to you winning and you
never know if that was the deciding
factor or not then they take it away I
am perfectly fine with people putting
asterisks next to baseball players names
I'm perfectly fine of Lance Armstrong
losing all the stuff that you know he
got as a result of that I think it sends
a good message namely that there's
certain limits and if you don't respect
those limits you don't belong in the
sport
you know sports are about taking human
beings and seeing what you can do with
them with proper training and the proper
training doesn't include taking you know
taking steroids or in other
performance-enhancing drugs now you know
there's questions about where do you
draw the lines and all that I'm not
really a competent person to tell you
about that but yeah I'm falling on the
side of take it away from them but I'd
say it's less from a philosophical
argument more my gut reaction
so this is a very nicely put question
how do we define hate speech as opposed
to speech that's objectively offensive
because no matter what you say no matter
how innocent it is somebody can take
offence at it and you know there's a lot
of stuff that's really frivolous that
some people might consider to be hate
speech on the other hand there are some
things that we want to say yeah that's
definitely hateful speech you've crossed
a line there and you shouldn't be doing
that so to two things if you look at our
how our society and how academics and
people in journalism in the legal
professions have dealt with these sorts
of things the covers you know fairly
wide range and it tends to be aligned
with traditional categories that are
used for in terms of discrimination that
said it tends to be very inconsistent so
you know if you say hateful things about
people of another race then it's
considered racism and then that's
considered hate speech right unless of
course you're say joking around
and if you're a professional comedian
maybe you can get away with it if you're
not one then maybe you can I mean
there's all sorts of inconsistencies
here if you're saying things about
somebody on the basis of gender can
that's very easy to categorize as hate
speech if you're talking about somebody
you know other protected categories like
somebody's veteran status oh you didn't
call veterans anything you like and it's
probably not gonna called hate speech
although perhaps maybe in some cases it
ought to be when it comes to religion
there are some religions that you can't
really say much about without incurring
you know somebody's saying how you're
being hateful and other religions where
even they're fair game you can say just
about anything you like so I didn't get
to the second part
shorter does Authority Authority and
expectations and desires always make
things right when you're in the working
and one of the things that some of my
students have stressed is that you know
when we're doing this ethic stuff it
seems really simple in the readings in
the classroom and all these abstract
examples but when you get into the
working world things start to see him a
lot murkier and and you're still faced
with the basic problem of you you have
to when you arrive it at certain
junctures you got to make decisions and
even in choosing not to make a decision
is in fact to choose some sort of course
of action even to be passive means
choosing something right so one thing
one option there is to sort of fall back
on what the people higher up the
authorities what their expectations are
what their desires are for you how they
see things what they would like to see
things go and should that be the
criteria should that always make things
right when you're in the working room no
you don't have to there they won't solve
every problem so you don't have to make
recourse to what authorities want
because maybe you know maybe they're not
good people maybe they're actually
misusing their authority maybe they're
morally blind maybe they have some sort
of ideology maybe they're exploiting you
or other people
does that mean that you should dismiss
them all together no but what it means
is that their expectations and desires
should probably be given the same amount
of weight as as everybody else who is
concerned by it so that that's worth
thinking about a little bit more
this is an interesting question the
biggest waste I know of because I'm sure
there's plenty of other wastes that I
have no idea of have to do with all the
food that ends up being thrown out from
restaurants or from other places that
are that are dealing with food there's a
lot of waste in this country with food
that could actually go and be consumed
by by people or even just by animals and
a lot of this has to do with our legal
climate it's very easy to get yourself
in trouble when you give somebody
something for free if something goes bad
is an easy way to say it and I think
what we ought to be doing is encouraging
restaurant owners people who own
anything that has to do with food to get
rid of the the surplus that's left over
say at the end of the night in ways that
can say feed the homeless or low-income
people or be distributed in other ways
not a lot has been done with that
unfortunately
isn't business ethics and oxymoron
you're the set a lot don't you along
with military intelligence and being
here nearby to Fort Bragg you learn very
quickly that that one is not a vaccine
more and business ethics is not an
oxymoron either it is quite possible to
conduct business in an ethical manner
there are many temptations to not doing
so there's many temptations to not think
about this to not to not do the right
thing at the right time and that's part
of how we wound up in the situation that
we're in where a lot of people distrust
corporations for one thing and they even
do tend to distrust business people not
as badly as they just trust politicians
of course but but yeah there is a lot of
distrust and that's because a lot of
businesses have not conducted themselves
in the way that they ought to
they created cultures of poor ethical
development and reasoning business
ethics as a discipline where philosophy
and you know the study of ethics and and
business issues and concerns
those are things applications come
together in an applied discipline and
it's one to which many people make
important contributions and there are a
lot of people out there studying it and
there are a lot of people out there
taking it seriously does that mean that
any given business person is necessarily
going to be a you know this paragon of
virtue no anymore than medical ethics
means that that's going to take place or
nursing ethics or engineering ethics but
I think it's a really important thing to
put in place and I don't think it's very
helpful to make a lot of jokes about how
business people are just corrupt or
anything like that
okay so yes I'm involved in something
called the ethics and business education
project and I was one of the co-founders
here at Fayetteville State University
now what's going to happen with it after
I leave the university is really up in
the air
we haven't actually settled that I am
going to continue with work in business
ethics and betting on what institution I
I find myself in I may do something
similar and it's part of a larger
project originally originally the goal
was to help them help the business
people set up ethics evaluations as part
of their specialized accreditation
because the accreditors said if you know
business ethics is really important you
guys don't have a lot of that we need to
see that you're actually teaching at
your classes so they came to the subject
matter experts you know the philosophers
and they said we need some help in in
putting together more and more ethics
things and I said yeah that sounds like
something I'd be interested in I was
actually at the time trying to write a
grant to create an ethics across the
curriculum program a much wider thing
and I may do that depending on where I
end up you know some other school a lot
of places already have business ethics
programs and quite often they're taught
by you know philosophers or their other
team taught by philosophers and
businesspeople actually I think that's
the best way to do but you know FSC was
a school with with relatively few
resources and the professor's have
pretty heavy loads we actually got some
some good progress done we created
rubrics we created assignments I helped
to train the graders I did some
workshops on ethical theories how to
evaluate student knowledge of them how
to evaluate application of them common
student issues that come up when you're
teaching ethics and
I think it was pretty good and I really
like working with the business people